eine neu entwickelte lithium metall
batterie setzt neue maßstäbe ein
forschungsteam aus deutschland hat jetzt
eine neue lithium metall batterie
ausgetüftelt die sich nicht nur durch
eine hohe energiedichte auszeichnet sie
ist zudem auch noch stabil und haltbar
kommen wir damit mit elektroautos
doppelt so weit geht so sei zum future
wegen des dramas spannende science
videos abonniert den kanal und activity
glocke nur so verpasst ihr nichts los
ganz
herzlich willkommen und so vor noch ein
hinweis in eigener sache meine
empfehlung für ein exklusives
weihnachtsgeschenk mein spiegel
bestseller tesla oder wyhlen maske die
elektromobilität revolutioniert von mir
handsigniert gibt es nur hier unter dem
link oder in der video beschreibung oder
als erster kommentar angepinnt für alle
die bekannte verwandte oder ihren
freundeskreis von der elektromobilität
überzeugen wollen hierunter mir einfach
draufklicken lange akkulaufzeiten müssen
her und zwar dringend nicht nur
elektroautos hätten somit eine deutlich
höhere reichweite auch das lästige
problem mit den handy akkus könnte so
bald der vergangenheit angehört und auch
andere batteriebetriebene produkte
könnten optimiert werden beispielsweise
hörgeräte die so weiter verkleinert
werden könnten manche fachleute weltweit
setzen auf lithium metall batterien und
das aus einem guten grund wie zum metall
weiterhin weisen eine extrem hohe
energiedichte auf sie speichern also pro
masse bzw volumen sehr viel mehr energie
als herkömmliche lithium ionen akkus so
könnten sie nach meinung vieler
wissenschaftlerinnen und wissenschaftler
zum beispiel die elektro mobilität
revolutionieren
denn hier sind kompakte und leichte
fahrzeuge mit einer hohen reichweite das
ziel und genau dabei kommen lithium
ionen batterien die bisher die gängige
lösung für die mobile stromversorgung
sind an ihre grenzen
sie sind relativ schwer wenn
elektroautos eine hohe reichweite haben
sollen deswegen wird die forschung an
sogenannten lithium metall batterien
intensiviert doch auch hier haben die
forschenden mit einem großen nachteil zu
kämpfen lithium metall batterien sind
bislang kaum wieder aufladbar und somit
quasi auch nicht denkbar für den einsatz
in der praxis doch ein forschungsteam
aus deutschland hat hier jetzt einen
durchbruch
st die wissenschaftlerinnen und
wissenschaftler vom karlsruher institut
für technologie und dem helmholtz
institut in ulm haben eine neue lithium
metall batterie entwickelt die nicht nur
eine hohe energiedichte aufweist sondern
auch stabil und haltbar ist selbst bei
mehr als 1000 ladezyklen verlor die
funktionierende labor zelle nur wenig
speicherkapazität eine batterie also die
alle rekorde brechen könnte und wie
genau ist das gelungen was bedeutet
dieser erfolg für unseren traum von
einer fast endlosen akkulaufzeit die
antworten auf all diese spannenden
fragen und noch viel mehr gibt es jetzt
nur hier bei pixum science in future
lithium metall batterien gelten als der
heilige gral der akku forschung schon
seit mehr als 40 jahren tüfteln
fachleute weltweit daran derartige
batterien zu entwickeln denn ihre hohe
kapazität und energiedichte sind einfach
zu verlockend doch es gibt ein
entscheidendes problem eine batterie auf
lithium metall zerstört sich quasi
selbst somit sind sie nicht
wiederaufladbar dahinter stecken einige
chemische prozesse das metallische
lithium lagert sich in form nadel
artiger spitzen an der anode ab und das
fatalerweise bereits nach wenigen
ladezyklen auch hier beim normalen
elektroautos passiert das aber deutlich
geringer so dass batterien dort ungefähr
nach heutigem stand so 800 1000
kilometer halten weitere probleme können
lithium stücke bilden die abbrechen
zudem bilden sich ablagerungen die
wiederum löcher in den separator reißen
können all das macht lithium metall
batterien bislang wirklich unbrauchbar
für den einsatz in der praxis einige
dinge wurden bislang schon in
verschiedenen experimenten ausprobiert
um genau diese probleme anzugehen
beispielsweise wurden spezielle
schutzschichten für den separator
eingesetzt oder aber neuartige
elektrolyte verwendet doch auf eine
wirklich zufriedenstellende lösung kann
man bislang nicht vor einigen monaten
meldete sich ein us forschungsteam mit
einem möglichen lösungsansatz die
fachleute hatten ein neues design
entwickelt um die unerwünschten nadel
artigen strukturen an der anode zu
verhindern diese sogenannten dendriten
die letztendlich die batterie zerstörer
also kurz schließen wollten sie mit
einer art sandwich batterie vermeiden
dafür setzen sie verschiedene
materialien ein die in dünnen schichten
zwischen der anode und katar oder
angeordnet wurden so errichteten die
wissenschaftlerinnen wissenschaftler
also eine art schutzschicht dazu sagt
einer der beteiligten forscher yuan je
unsere strategie instabilität zu
integrieren um so die batterie zu
stabilisieren fühlt sich zunächst
befremdlich an aber genau wie ein dübel
eine schraube führen und steuern kann
kann auch unsere mehrschichtige
konstruktions anleitung das wachstum von
den briten führen und steuern der
unterschied besteht darin dass unser
google schnell sehr fest wird und der
denn trittin nicht durch bohren kann so
dass ein wachstum gestoppt wird doch
klar ist auch dass es hier noch ein
weiter weg ist bis diese lithium
batterie in serie gehen kann einen
anderen ansatz verfolgt das
forschungsteam vom helmholtz institut in
ulm und dem karlsruher institut für
technologie kit die fachleute haben eine
neue lithium batterie entwickelt und
dabei eine nickel reiche kobalt aber
schicht kathode verwendet diese weist
eine hohe energiedichte auf doch das
bislang verwendete organische elektrolyt
mit der bezeichnung lp 30 führte nicht
zur gewünschten stabilität dazu sagt
stefano passerini vom helmholtz institut
ulm im elektrolyten lp 30 entstehen
partikel risse an der kathode innerhalb
dieser risse reagiert der elektrolyt und
zerstört die struktur zudem bildet sich
eine dicke großartige lithium haltige
schicht auf der kathode extrem schade da
es so bislang unmöglich war dieser
batterie mehr als nur einen ladezyklus
effektiv zu nutzen die
wissenschaftlerinnen und wissenschaftler
aus karlsruhe und ulm kamen also auf die
idee einen neuen elektrolyten
einzusetzen der die kathode schützt zu
der nickel reichen kobalt abendschicht
kathode kombinierten sie also einen
schwer flüchtigen nicht entflammbaren
flüssig elektrolyten zwar negativ
geladene organische verbindungen
übernehmen hier quasi den transport der
ladung in der fachsprache werden sie als
sogenannte ihm idee bezeichnet dazu
schreibt das forschungsteam in der
aktuellen studie mit hilfe dieses
elektrolyten lassen sich die
strukturveränderung an der nickel
reichen katte wesentlich eindämmen die
fachleute konnten herausfinden wie der
neue
rüthen die kathode schützt und zwar
indem er eine schicht an der grenze zur
kathode bildet was genau passiert
erklärt krug der an der studie beteiligt
war diese schicht bewahrt die kathode
vor zerstörerischen reaktionen mit dem
elektrolyten und verhindert so die
irreversiblen phasen transformation des
hexagonal kristallgitters an seiner
oberfläche und nicht nur das die schicht
die sich durch den neuen elektrolyten
bildet verhindert dass sich mikrorisse
weiter ausbreiten der vergleich mit
zellen derselben bauart die aber über
einen gewöhnlichen organischen
elektrolyten verfügung überraschte
selbst die fachleute mit den normalen
elektrolyten sank die kapazität deutlich
mit jedem zyklus gab die batterien 0,63
millivolt weniger ab ganz im gegenteil
bei der lithium metall batterie die mit
dem neuen elektrolyten ausgestattet war
beim laden und entladen blieb die
spannung fast stabil die das
forschungsteam in der aktuellen studie
berichtet hier blieb die kapazität bei
mehr als 1000 ladezyklen zu 88 prozent
erhalten dazu heißt es in der
pressemitteilung des beteiligten
karlsruher instituts für technologie
die lithium metall batterie erreicht mit
der kathode ncm 88 und dem
elektronischen e eine energiedichte von
560 wattstunden pro kilogramm
bezogen auf das gesamtgewicht der aktiv
materialien die wissenschaftlerinnen und
wissenschaftler in der akku forschung
interessiert hierbei vor allem die
sogenannte cool und effizienz die das
verhältnis zwischen entnommen und zu
geführter kapazität angibt bei der neu
entwickelten die zehn meter batterie
beträgt diese durchschnittlich 99 94
prozent wie eben bereits erwähnt konnte
die lithium metall zelle durch das kind
und der kathode und dem einsatz des
neuen elektrolyten eine energiedichte
von 560 wattstunden pro kilogramm
aufweisen damit ist die energiedichte
mehr als doppelt so hoch wie bei
aktuellen elektroautos die fachleute aus
ulm karlsruhe wir zeichnen ihre neu
entwickelte batterie zu dem als sehr
sicher und so bringt diese entwicklung
künftige lithium metall akkus und deren
einsatz in der praxis ein großes stück
nach vorne auch wenn noch keine
industrie fertigen batterie entwickelt
wurde zeigt die funktionieren der labor
zelle dass sich weitere forschung in
diesem bereich lohnen könnte und hier
noch einmal eine kleine aufklärung zur
lithium
das batteriematerialien ist deutlich
umweltfreundlicher als die
erdölgewinnung und die ressourcen sind
wohl unerschöpflicher lithium extrem oft
vorkommt wie zum beispiel in deutschland
im rheingraben wo es in
geothermiekraftwerken einfach gewonnen
werden kann zudem wird das meiste
lithium aktuell in bergwerken gefördert
und selbst wenn es in salzseen gewonnen
wird ist der wasserverbrauch mindestens
500 mal geringer als bei der
erdölförderung aktuell die zudem für
viel schlimmere verseuchung der umwelt
verantwortlich ist mehr dazu und noch
viele viele weitere verblüffende fakten
zur elektromobilität gibt es hier in
meinem spiegel bestseller tesla oder wie
ihre maske elektromobilität
revolutioniert und den gibt es also hier
oder in der video beschreibung oder im
ersten kommentar und das von mir
persönlich signiert viel spaß beim lesen
den haben nämlich die meisten wenn man
so die bewertung liest also bis dann
bleib dran